the number of US service members
infected by the corona virus at Marine
bases in Okinawa has now risen to 136
back home Marines are taking the fight
to the virus by participating in a
comprehensive study on how it spreads
among the young mark Strassmann is in
South Carolina where he got an exclusive
look at what's being done there mark
good morning to you can't wait to see
good morning Gail this is Parris Island
where they make Marines it's boot camp
hell for any recruit from east of the
Mississippi I'm standing in an area
known as Leatherneck square and all
around me recruits are going through a
confidence course here is what they're
up against the course itself is
challenging it's summer in South
Carolina and now their breathing is even
harder because they all have to wear
masks it's one more way the Marines are
trying to keep an invisible threat
outside the wire at Parris Island their
Marines and training already facing
their first battle kovat it's why
they're quarantined here at the Citadel
for two weeks before heading to Parris
Island Koba 19 is brand new and we don't
know much about it but the Marines first
to fight believe a Cove encounter attack
starts with cutting-edge research
immunologist Andrew Letizia is also a
navy commander he's leading a Navy
Marine deep dive into why young people
like this group fight off kovat better
than most for the military the virus
threat can lurk anywhere so you'll have
individuals that are training together
they are eating together they are in
barracks and sleeping together as well
certainly respiratory viruses including
kovat 19 can spread like wildfire in it
in that situation it did aboard the USS
Theodore Roosevelt back in March 1200
sailors aboard the naval aircraft
carrier tested positive while at sea in
the Pacific one sailor died the kovat
threat was on the radar of every
military branch no one saw this coming
Colonel Rico player commands the kovat
task force at Parris Island this study I
think is critical because there there's
so many unknowns how much your time now
is spent trying to keep your folks
healthy 80%
90% depending it affects all of us
because we can't see it it's everywhere
but nowhere at the Citadel Leticia's
volunteers give saliva samples nasal
swabs and blood draws anyone testing
kovat positive will be tracked and
retested at least six times over eight
weeks researchers here also want to
learn more about how the virus spreads
and how long someone's immune system
will keep up the fight trying to figure
out who makes antibodies does everybody
make antibodies how robust is that
antibody response in order to identify
the virus and effectively neutralize it
in the future if you were to be reexpose
we can then apply that knowledge of our
immunology towards developing the next
frontier of medicines as well as
vaccines and compare their findings with
the immunology zuv people more
vulnerable to the virus volunteer altoro
Marrero knows what's at stake coming
from Miami it's a pretty big thing right
now especially recently for the Marines
beating the virus would help protect
their operational readiness but this
research could also reach another
battlefield
that's the nationwide fight against the
virus I think some of the questions that
we're really attempting to answer will
help in their reopening of America this
group needs to stay healthy
ask any marine who went through basic
training at Parris Island they have
enough to worry about with the drill
instructor without having to worry about
Kovac it's fair to say when they arrived
at Parris Island they are clean and
ready to train the drill instructors
will take care of the rest of that and
the drill instructors will take care of
it right now you can see some of the
recruits some of them are also being
Leticia's test groups several hundred of
them will be in the group he plans to
publish his preliminary findings next
month and like any successful battle
plan here's the key
know your enemy don't it that's right
mark I enjoy the slightly demented smile
there from the drill instructor at the
end they can beat the virus the drill
instructors will take care of the rest
indeed mark Strassmann for us mark thank
you very much